okay I am thrilled to announce that
today we had a 3532 dollar donation made
to the IndieGoGo campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate that is the
matching donation from last week's
matching grant challenge so we are now
roughly at twenty thousand dollars
raised which jut with just over a week
to go the day of Donald Trump's
inauguration is the last day of our
campaign we now have a new high
watermark donation of 3532 dollars
although really that's a matching
donation so in reality the top donations
are to five hundred dollar donations one
from Sarah one from Nick and then a four
hundred and ninety nine dollar donation
from Joshua so I am opening up a sort of
colloquial challenge a casual challenge
for a 501 dollar donation I think that
somebody's going to do it yeah that's
kind of the prices right strategy
someone will go 501 and then maybe 50
2503 look at the war on media being
increasingly waged by Donald Trump the
next four years are going to be insane
with regard to media we've got the fake
news allegations fake news now being
attached to any news you don't like
Trump wanting to make it easier to sue
media outlets through libel law suits we
clearly now have tiers of media in
Donald Trump's mind we're clearly
Breitbart is near the top of the list
CNN near the bottom of the list and who
knows who's in between so please donate
what you can we're going to coordinate
progressive media over the next four
years david pakman.com slash donate even
if you can only donate a few bucks
donate a few bucks we've had countless
one dollar donation to dollar donations
three four five dollar donations they
add up if you've got a few bucks sitting
around in an old paypal account that you
don't use anymore throw them in all
donations welcome at david pakman.com
slash donate